die wasser spitzensportler des
bundesheeres dürfen endlich wieder
trainieren
auf der wiener donauinsel werden nach
der trainings zwangspause die boote zu
wasser gelassen der befehl zur aufnahme
neuer trainingseinheiten der kommt von
der verteidigungsministerin persönlich
ein befehl den es für die mittlerweile
trainings hungrigen ruderer und kanuten
nicht gebraucht hätte
viele von ihnen sind ja für die
olympischen spiele bereits qualifiziert
die verschiebung der spiele kommt aber
nicht überraschend die nachricht war
nicht so überraschend man hat schon
damit rechnen können wenn man die medien
verfolgt hat dass es zu einer
verschiebung kommen wird wenn jetzt
sogar zu einer kompletten streichung der
spiele wie es auch kommen wird auf die
form der wassersportler hat das
offensichtlich keinen einfluss ich
glaube die olympia pause keine große
auswirkung auf die form für die den
haben die spieler haben werde da die
spiele um ein jahr verschoben worden
sind und somit eigentlich jetzt mehr
zeit zur vorbereitung ist und das für
uns so noch einmal an größeren vorteil
hat dass wir schon wissen
bruderer oder kanuten die motivation für
künftige bewerbe ist voll da und eines
vereint aber alle das training wieder
losgeht und das wird auch gleich voll
ausgenützt in der hoffnung das kommende
wettkämpfe nicht wieder krisenbedingt
ins wasser fallen